bonjour françois poulet mathis merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france même s'il y avait des
rumeurs comment est ce que vous
expliquez cette annonce soudaine de
remanier le jour même de l'annoncé boris
johnson a dit tout à l'heure on va
remanier et il commence dès le jour même
je crois que boris johnson a besoin d'un
nouveau souffle pour prendre le relais
d'une part de la pandémie qu'il estime
maîtriser actuellement ce qui est pas
encore tout à fait assuré et puis aussi
pour les échéances futures pour
l'automne l'hiver qui s'annonce à un
automne et un hiver à risque et aussi
pour affronter ce que le break site lui
réservera probablement comme surprise
plus ou moins facile donc il a besoin
d'un nouveau souffle à cela s'ajoute
quand même une réalité c'est qu'il était
en difficulté y compris dans l'opinion
publique britannique un sondage tout à
fait récent montre que le parti
conservateur
offre plus audi plus de défiance que le
parti travailliste qui passe en tête
donc déjà cette situation est une
situation à risques la deuxième
situation à risque c'est qu'il est même
critiqué au sens au sein de son propre
camp le camp conservateur qui lui et
souhaite ne pas revenir dans des
situations par exemple de confinement et
donc il a pris un très gros pari il a
pris le pari de faire un plan sans
confinement sans mesures barrières c'est
à dire d'alléger complètement les
restrictions sanitaires pour faire face
à la pandémie or le variant delta et
bien au royaume uni et ce variant d'état
continuent à faire des dégâts le système
de santé britannique est extrêmement
fragilisée par la pandémie est le pari
qu'il a pris c'est effectivement de
maintenir ce qu'il a déjà institué avec
ce qu'on appelait le freedom day c'est à
dire le jour de liberté l'espace de
liberté dans lesquelles les britanniques
aujourd'hui retrouvez cet espace de
liberté plus le basque obligatoires plus
de mesures barrières et bien c'est un
grand paris parce que effectivement est
ce que ces dispositions réussiront à
maintenir quand même le contrôle de la
pandémie
c'est une véritable question qui
aujourd'hui opposés donc il lui fallait
un nouveau souffle et ce nouveau souffle
ils le trouvent en prenant des gens de
confiance qui vont pouvoir avec qui n'a
pour avoir confiance pour affronter ces
défis et en particulier défi de
l'automne et l'hiver et défis d'une
réussite on vous parlait beaucoup de la
pandémie de kobe il ya eu déjà des
annonces 1 on l'a donc dit dominique
rabe qui quittent les le cabinet du
ministère des affaires étrangères pour
aller à la justice pour remplacer robert
buckland et par exemple au niveau
de la santé puisque vous parlez de la
pandémie est ce que là va y avoir un
remaniement ou pas abbas est attendu
dans la mesure où effectivement le poids
qui pèse sur le système de santé quand
même assez redoutable ce qui a obligé le
gouvernement britannique et boris
johnson en particulier de déclencher un
alourdissement des dépenses de santé et
ses talents vieillissement finalement
nantes les charges les charges et les
charges c'est quelque chose qui
finalement se traduire en impôts or le
gouvernement britannique de gordon
s'était engagé à ne pas augmenter les
impôts eh bien il est obligé de le faire
car le système de santé britannique a
tellement souffert de cette pandémie
qu'il faut intervenir effectivement pour
le regonfler à la plupart et d'argent
juste au niveau de l'information
enrichie sous n'a qu'un l'actuel
locataire
chancelier de l'échiquier donc ministre
des finances est confirmée il reste à
son poste lui bon soit et donc il va
avoir comme mission importante
effectivement de faire en sorte que le
cese système de santé ne souffre pas
trop je vous rappelle que bord une
chaussade a prévu une deux options une
option dans lequel effectivement la
pandémie serait maîtrisée continuerait à
être maîtrisé malgré la levée des
mesures de restrictions sanitaires
auquel cas effectivement en continuerait
de cette manière là en soutenant le
système de santé comme le soutient
actuellement si toutefois il devait y
avoir une augmentation très sérieuse de
l'épidémie diffusion de l'épidémie
la borie jones à se réserve la
possibilité d'un plan b c'est à dire la
possibilité effectivement de
réintroduire des mesures de restrictions
très sévères
dominique rabe qui va donc à la justice
je les dis les remplacer par istres et
seul du côté du commerce qui va donc
devenir chef de la diplomatie à deux
ministres ont quitté le gouvernement
avant même ses annonces et gavin
williamson le ministre de l'éducation et
donc robert buckland je dédie d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure à la justice d'autres
ministres sont menacés comme pretty
pâtit patel notamment à l'intérieur
crétier critiqué pour la gestion des
migrants venant de france notamment
quels sont les portefeuilles qui sont
susceptibles de changer donc l'intérieur
on vient de le dire est ce qui en a
d'autres
d'autres oreilles faut voir l'intérieur
c'est très important parce que
effectivement l'afflux d'immigrants sur
les côtes anglaises a mis un petit peu
en fureur le gouvernement britannique
est ce qui a fait dire à mme johnson que
la france ne fait pas le job de
maintenir d'arrêter les migrants qui
partent de chez elle vers les côtes
britanniques et donc ce qui met
effectivement en fragilité le ministre
de l'intérieur donc qui est directement
visé et puis le mythe de l'éducation
c'est la même chose on lui a reproché
beaucoup finalement l'idée d'avoir fermé
les écoles pendant toute la période de
l'épidémie ce qui était effectivement
très dommageable pour les jeunes
britanniques donc ces deux ministères
effectivement sont directement en cause
pour les autres il faut voir il faut il
faut voir et étudié en fonction des
différentes domination juste un dernier
mot françois poulet mathis vous parliez
de sondages tout à l'heure comment
réagit la la population britannique avec
cette annonce d'aujourd'hui par rapport
à ceux à ce remaniement il est trop tôt
pour le dire la seule chose que l'on
peut dire c'est que ben johnson avait
obtenu une confiance très large des
britanniques aux premières élections
législatives et qu'aujourd'hui cette
confiance a l'air de s'éroder un peu
donc si johnson doit affronter comme le
sait doit affronter à la fois livre
l'hiver l'automne l'hiver avec les
risques notamment d'une épidémie de
grippe qui pourrait être elle aussi
dévastatrice et puis affronter le
deuxième dossier qui a été un petit peu
masqué masquée par la pandémie s'est lui
aussi lubrique site qui fragilise aussi
l'économie britannique eh bien il ya
besoin d'une équipe très serré une
équipe très unie et pour ça il ne
pouvait pas se permettre d'avoir des
gens sur lequel ils pouvaient pas
comptés de manière suffisante merci
françois poulet mathis pour votre
analyse et votre expertise rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste des
questions des institutions européennes
et les spécialistes également de la
grande bretagne